so to remind you we've been talking last
week
about kind of doing two things at once
asking all set of questions of what we
might want to know about face perception
in the brain there are some questions
but at the same time the agenda has been
to consider the different methods
available in human cognitive
neuroscience and what kinds of questions
each one can answer okay
so last week we talked about a bunch of
them and today we're going to wrap this
up talking about tms and animal studies
but first i just want to remind you very
briefly i won't go through in
excruciating detail we talked about
behavioral methods which are great for
characterizing internal representations
as you saw with face inversion effects
um and uh and some of the other
behavioral data
they have major disadvantages which is
that with behavior you're just measuring
the output it's pretty sparse and from
that you have to infer all the stuff
that happened in between
the retina or whatever your sensory
modality is and that would put all that
internal mental stuff you have to infer
just from the output so it's amazing
that that works at all and you have to
be really smart to do it and lots of
people have been doing that for a long
time but it's challenging so why not
look inside and one of the best ways to
do that of course is functional mri it
has the best spatial resolution
available for normal subjects
but as you guys all seem to pick up on
its temporal resolution is lousy
and its ability to tell you whether the
neural activity you're looking at is
causally involved in behavior is like
nil
okay now at least one of you i only read
a few of the assignments uh but at least
one of you was confused about which
causal role we're talking about and this
is actually really important
so let's take a moment to talk about
this
causality the idea of causality if x
causes y
that means essentially y wouldn't have
happened without x or y happened more
because x happened
when x happens then when x doesn't
happen okay so that's pretty basic right
so that means if you want to test the
causal rule of x on y
you have to mess with x
okay that's the key challenge
okay so with that in mind here's this
whole causal chain a stimulus lands on a
retina a bunch of neural activity
happens and some behavioral output
happens there's a whole causal chain
there now let's consider what kind of
causality we're talking about
there's one kind which is that the
stimulus causes neural activity in the
brain
that's a kind of causality that we can
absolutely test even if we're measuring
that with functional mri because we can
mess with the stimulus we can present
different stimuli and produce different
neural activity okay so in that case
we can look at the causal effect of the
stimulus on the neural activity no
problem that's standard that's what we
do pretty much in every
um every experiment with erps or
functional mri or so forth is that clear
okay
on the other hand if we want to know
this kind of causality from some neural
activity we measure in the brain
to either a behavioral response or a
subjective feeling reported by a
behavioral response or something like
that that's the challenging part that's
the kind of causality that we can't
infer from erps or functional mri
everyone got that
yeah okay it's sort of like obvious and
not obvious
okay
so let's um let's talk a little bit more
about that temporal resolution i know i
kept saying the temporal resolution of
functional memory is lousy but i had run
out of time and skip through the key
slides so let me back up and do that
here
this is the bold or mri response as a
function of time this is an idealized
version of it but it looks kind of like
that
and
sorry these these things are tiny here
but these are seconds five seconds 10
seconds
so let me show you what that means if
you're recording
neural activity back here in the first
stage of visual processing in the cortex
coming up from the eyes which is where
the occipital lobe yes what area
primary visual cortex exactly okay so
suppose
that we
stuck an electrode in my primary visual
cortex
and we flashed up a very brief visual
display
okay here's a visual stimulus on for
maybe a tenth of a second bright
flashing thing v1 loves
v1 also primary visual cortex right okay
the neural activity would happen in less
than a tenth of a second super fast
we know that from work in animals and
even some work in humans okay so super
fast after the stimulus okay it just
goes straight up from the retina the lg
and v1 boom there it is
so all the neural activity happens right
there and ends right there
but the mri response
is five six seconds later this big
sloppy slow thing as the blood sloshes
into v1 many seconds after the relevant
neural activity okay so what's relevant
here is not just that it's delayed but
it's big and sloppy
right and so both of those things are
the reasons why
functional mri responses
aren't good for distinguishing what
happens on a fine temporal scale of say
events less than a second
okay all right
um
okay
in contrast as i mentioned when you glue
electrodes on the scalp or stick these
fancy magnetic sensors in the big
hairdryer device around your head
there you get beautiful temporal
resolution
but it's like you know the heisenberg
principle of cognitive neuroscience you
want time you don't get space right okay
and similarly here we can measure the
causal effect on um scalp response
neural responses
um
but not
not the causal role of those neural
responses on behavior everyone clear
with this okay
um okay then i talked about um
these rare cases where we can record
um directly from the surface of the
human brain with electrical activity
where we now get both space and time
at the same time
and the key disadvantage there of course
is that it's extremely invasive you have
to take a big piece of skull off to get
in there
and of course that would only happen in
the case of people who are already in
pretty
pretty serious medical circumstances
okay so now when we have this incredible
opportunity to record this amazing data
from the center of the brain does that
enable us to make this kind of causal
inference from neural activity to
behavior
yes what do you think yes no
isabel is that isabelle yes why are you
shaking your head um
because it just tells us what your
parents are responsible for
that's right it's it's cooler it's it's
it's fancier it's more impressive than
functional mri or erps but it's still
the same deal we're just recording
responses okay
so we can do this causality from the
from the stimulus to those neural
responses but it doesn't tell us which
of those responses are related to
behavior yet right i showed you other
methods that do but this one alone
doesn't everybody got that
all right
um
so then i talked about studying patients
with vocal brain damage
um and here you really can make a strong
causal link between a bit of brain and a
behavioral ability you lose that bit of
brain you can no longer do that task
that's a that's a really direct kind of
causal
role
i talked about double dissociations i
gave it short shrift but it's actually
really important you should know it
a double dissociation is when you have
one patient who can do a but not b say
recognize objects but not faces and
another patient who can do b but not a
say recognize faces but not objects and
when you have in the literature two
cases like that now you're in a really
strong position to infer that there's
something fundamentally different about
face recognition and object recognition
in the brain okay so that's really
important the senses in which a double
association is more inferentially
powerful than a single dissociation
okay
more important means i'm sure to test
you on it
no it's also important whether i was
going to test you on it or not
okay
and so of course in focal brain damage
we
we can absolutely infer causal role from
a bit of brain to a behavioral ability
lose that bit of brain lose the ability
yeah
okay
um and um the the case that i showed you
with that amazing movie of the guy
getting stimulated in his fusiform face
area and seeing percepts of faces on top
of whatever he looked at that's a kind
of quintessential beautiful example of
the causal role of neural activity there
we're basically
directly manipulating neural activity
we're injecting neural activity there
electrically and looking at
the behavioral and cognitive result that
that occurs the guy sees a hallucinatory
face
okay
okay
now
that is amazing data but as i mentioned
we it's they're very rare we have no
control over it when we get those data
we celebrate and are all excited but
mostly we don't get those data
and so um
and plus those people have serious
problems with their brains that's why
their brains are being opened up
so
is there any way to test the causal role
of a particular part of the brain in a
normal subject who doesn't have their
skull open for neurosurgery and who has
not had brain damage
well there's one way
and that's called transcranial magnetic
stimulation okay
so in transcranial magnetic stimulation
you take a coil of wire about yay big
that's you know tight wrapped coil of
wire embedded in plastic connected to a
ginormous capacitor
and you hold it next to your head of
course that's what you would do if
you're a neuroscientist
and you discharge and make an enormous
current through that coil that's very uh
very strong and very brief the whole
thing lasts less than one millisecond
and you guys know from 802 another case
of the right-hand rule coming to our
service
you have a hell of a current going in a
coil what's going to happen in brain
tissue underneath
increase the magnetic field
electric field
yeah exactly
and so
you'll get electric field perpendicular
to the coil sticking right into the
brain like that and what do you think
happens if you stick a big huge
transient electric field boom into your
head like that
is another magnetic field
uh yeah you're right right hand rule's
magnetic field i was thinking i was
misremembering right electric current
makes magnetic field right
it was a long time ago i took 802.
i did just a long time ago
anyway for current purpose it doesn't
matter either either would do it
actually there's a variant of this where
it's an electric field but
it's debated how well that works okay
anyway
what happens is you affect neural
activity and tissue right underneath the
skull right
okay um so
um
if you want to see a picture a video of
that happening there's a video of me
getting zapped with tms on my website
you can check it out it's kind of
ludicrous yes question what's the
spatial resolution oh we're getting
there we're getting there
okay here's an early version of this to
generate these very strong and brief
magnetic fields they had these stacks of
coils like this and they rotated them
around it's a little crazy here's a more
recent version it looks like a big
torture device but it's actually no big
deal the guy's just holding his head on
a chin rest hold his head still and
there's a person holding the coil next
to his head
like that
and so
that enables us to briefly and somewhat
selectively disrupt a little patch of
cortex there by sticking in this big
random field
uh now spatial resolution is not amazing
maybe one two centimeters something like
that okay it's better than you might
guess for such an incredibly crude
device like something people would have
done 100 years ago and yet we still do
it today
you can also
use a lovely method where you scan the
subject with functional mri first find a
particular functional region that you're
interested in in that person's brain
remember these things can vary in their
exact location across subjects
and then find a whole way to register
externally on the on the scalp what is
the closest spot to that region you
found in their brain previously with
functional mri and stick the coil right
there and exactly titrate its location
with reference to that brain image okay
so that makes this whole enterprise more
worthwhile so what can tms tell us about
face perception
well here's the problem
here's my fusiform face area that guy
right there
it's a few centimeters in from the scalp
from the skull
so that's a drag unless we opened up my
head we can't reach it there with the
tms coil believe me the first time i had
a chance to use a tms coil the very
first thing i did was stick the coil
there crank it to the max and try to see
what would happen
not a damn thing happened it was very
disappointing i knew lots of friends who
tried the same thing it was the most
obvious thing it just doesn't work it's
too medial yeah but there was a question
over here a moment ago uh
if you use tms like near someone's brain
stem
yeah that wouldn't be so smart
luckily the brain stem is kind of deep
in there
so if you were really stupid and stuck
it down i don't know way in here you
might be able to cause trouble but
mostly people don't stick it back there
and actually the subjects won't let you
anyway because there's a lot of neck
muscles and it really hurts when you do
tms
over muscles and so if anybody had such
a stupid ideas to try to set the brain
stem
the subject would probably like object
immediately before they got very far
with it because because what hurt
and you guys are all probably wondering
how safe is this um
it's not totally clear there have been
lots of studies in animals
where they you know
zap a rabbit you know a hundred thousand
times or something like that and say
well rabbit seems fine hops around you
know
and the best they can do in animal
studies when i first used tms around 20
years ago i
i read a few basic safety studies and i
thought god i don't know and i and i but
i also realized that if you look at the
papers the initials of the subjects were
the same as the authors
so i called them up and i said hey you
know tell me honestly like did you guys
ever
notice any ill effects from getting
zapped
and the guys talked to said yeah i've
been zapped about 10 000 times and i
never noticed anything except for one
thing
after a whole hour of getting zapped it
gave me a hell of a craving for ice
cream
so i decided okay i can do i can live
with that we got it through the human
subjects committee and we do a you know
not a lot but some tms in my lab and i'm
probably but now been zapped at least as
many times as that kind and i guess you
guys can judge for yourself so you don't
have the before conditions so it's a
little hard
anyway
as far as anybody can tell it's a
perfectly safe yes i would say there are
some contraindications if you are prone
to seizures
medications so if you ever sign up for
tms study read the five print good good
point yep
okay so back to this um it will be
lovely to zap that guy uh but it's too
hard to reach
okay
so then this guy david pitcher came
along and he had a very good idea
and my um you know 1970s synopsis of his
idea paraphrasing
stills is if you can't zap the region
you love love the region you can
and so uh pitcher said hey what about
that other guy there we haven't talked a
lot about it it's sometimes called the
occipital face area i think of it as a
kind of
crappy version of the ffa it's kind of
face selective it's not as face
selective it's more variable so it's not
as fun to study but it's there in most
people
i have a damn fine one i have to say
many people do and it is right out there
next to the scalp
just asking for it right okay
um so here's what david pitcher did
he gave subjects
a uh you need a behavioral task right
because in this case
we're testing the causal role of a bit
of brain on behavior so we're going to
measure behavior and so what is our task
okay
um so here's his task sorry it's a
little tiny but this is this is one
trial time is going this way you present
a face there's a brief interval you
present another face and the task is
just are those two faces same or
different okay it's kind of your basic
face perception task but then what you
can do
is you can zap the occipital face area
at different time in you know during
presentation of that second phase
and you can do it at different time
intervals remember its effect is very
brief
the actual magnetic change is less than
a millisecond
okay
so here's what david pitcher found in
that study this is accuracy at this same
different matching task
when you stimulate the right occipital
face area versus vertex that means you
stick the coil up here which is pretty
far away from face regions it's kind of
a controlled condition not a perfect one
but better than nothing
by the way tms usually doesn't hurt
unless you stick it over muscles you
stick it over the frontal lobes and i
don't know every time i try to disrupt
my language abilities it hurts too much
because there are muscles up there
but most places like the top of the head
there aren't muscles and it doesn't
really doesn't really hurt but it still
makes a loud cracking noise and it's
kind of like somebody went like that
so you might imagine you need a control
condition right because if people are uh
that also has a tms pulse right if you
bang somebody on the head when they're
trying to do a task you probably disrupt
their performance so you need to bang
them somewhere else to see if it's
specific to that location okay
so um okay so here's a little effect of
accuracy it's not a huge effect size
okay so here it's going from you know 85
correct to 70 percent correct when you
zap
occipital face area compared to vertex
everybody get what's going on here
so that's good that tells us something
zapping here messes up face perception
more than zapping here
okay
okay so that tells us something about
causal role
but what else would you want to know
that's a beginning
but having just learned what i told you
about tms what else could you do that
would tell you more
yeah do you see faces
ah well that's a good question it wasn't
what i was fishing for but it's a very
good point so this shows disruption but
i showed you with that video before that
if you electrically stimulate the ffa
you see a face
well unfortunately nobody has reported
that when you zap a face area you see a
percept of a face boy that would be fun
if true but it doesn't work
and there's much debate about why
it probably has to do with the fact that
your ability to target just that region
is less good than it is with direct
stimulation
there are many reports and many
published studies where if you zap v1
you see a flash of light
okay
i don't see the damn flash of light i've
tried and tried and tried
and you know people in my lab who i
trust promise me they actually see it
isn't just bs but
i don't know i don't see it
anyway
so probably
the question of when you get disruption
and when you get a positive percept is a
very interesting complicated one i think
it will ultimately have to do with
how those batches of neurons
not only respond to faces or light or
whatever but how they code for that
information such that when you put a big
um
kind of artifactual non-biological
signal in there will it have any meaning
that the subject can interpret
i don't know if that's helpful it's not
i i don't i think nobody really
understands that
when you'll get a positive persecutor
but i hope you can at least understand
that at least if you mess with it and
muck it up you can disrupt that logic is
clear
when you will be able to actually stick
in a signal and get a positive coherent
percept as a is a
is a more subtle thing
okay
okay what else would you want to know
yes
whether it was object perception or not
absolutely
absolutely all we're showing here is
it's messing up face perception maybe
the guy can't see here right maybe he's
just globally blind maybe he'd have the
same problem with object perception
absolutely the assigned reading for
wednesday shows exactly that experiment
okay
what else would you want to know
remember a tms pulse lasts less than a
millisecond
that enables us to ask a whole
interesting kind of question
what else could we find out
yeah there's the x-axis yeah
yeah i'm sorry i don't mean to be
insulting your intelligence you're
probably sitting there saying this is
too obvious that's all i'm talking about
you can zap at different times and ask
when is information going through there
when is that region playing a causal
role in behavior and here is a very
beautiful data that david got and
there's basically no effect at any point
other than that interval between uh
8
60 and 100 milliseconds
okay so that's cool tells you that's
when that region is likely engaged in
processing
make sense
okay
um
and
is it char dual yes already made the
point i was going to ask you guys does
this tell us this region is specifically
involved in face perception absolutely
not we'd have to test other things right
could affect everything you every visual
percept
right
okay so you can read more about that
all right just so to collect all the
advantages it gives you strong causal
evidence that a particular part of the
brain is involved in perception or
behavior
uh it has good temporal information
unlike studying patients with vocal
brain damage
and it is the only disruption method
that can be used in normal humans okay
so that's why even though it's so crude
and rudimentary we use it because it's
the only thing that kind of fills that
niche
a couple other unimportant things
spatial resolution isn't as good as we'd
like but it's surprising how much you
can learn nonetheless
um
and doesn't reach very far below the
scalp although ed boyden the amazing ed
boyden is working on a crazy new version
of it that might
okay so where have all this
this kind of menagerie of methods
gotten us to i won't go through all this
in detail we listed all these questions
before i gave you some of the answers
from previous methods the ones we've
just talked about show for example that
the fusiform face area or the occipital
face area in the case of tms
are causally involved in face perception
apparently not in object perception
pending the paper you're going to read
and so that's important because it says
when we try to come up with you know
theories of how face recognition works
we might think about having a different
theory for face recognition from our
theory of object recognition right
okay
so this is all magnificent and wonderful
but
i finessed this list of questions so
that the methods would be able to
address them at least a little bit
and i sneakily left off a whole suite of
other questions
that are extremely important arguably
more important that those methods don't
address
okay
so we want to know not just that a
region responds to faces we want to know
exactly what is represented in that
region or other regions that respond to
other things
we want to know what is the neural code
for faces
okay
we want to know what are the actual
computations that go on in a given
region how do they unfold over time
and how do those computations produce
the representations and behavioral
abilities that we measure
we want to know what are the actual
anatomical connections i showed you that
little occipital face area right nearby
but discontiguous from the fusiform face
area i've wanted to know for 20 years
whether those damn things are connected
anatomically
shockingly we still don't know that
okay
we want to know what is the causal role
of each region in perception i showed
you a few ways that we get little bits
of data kind of sort of but there's a
lot of cases where we don't
so
um and we and we want to know how does
all this stuff get wired up over
development right
what is the role of experience do you
need to see faces to wire up the face
region or is it there at birth before
you ever see a face right
the sad truth is
for the most part we don't have good
methods to answer these questions in
humans
okay so that's just a big bummer but
it's true
most of these questions can only be
answered by research and animals or can
be best answered by research in animals
okay
so i'm going to take a moment to talk
about ethical issues in animal research
just to note that i think there is an
issue
and i'll say that it's not unreasonable
if you have qualms i noticed an earlier
lecture i started talking about
recording from animal brains and i
didn't have time at that moment to mark
this but i do think it's important
if it makes you uneasy
that's totally legitimate you should
think about that and respect that and
think hard about whether that's you know
what you make of that
unambiguously
causing animals pointless suffering is
just completely unacceptable okay so i
think we can all agree on that
and i think there's a very difficult
trade-off
between avoiding suffering in animals
and research that has saved countless
lives
people can legitimately come down on
different sides of this
uh but many lives have been saved
including mine based on animal research
that enabled treatments that were
life-saving
and a few things to think about to help
you
inform how you handle that trade-off
first of all know that animal research
in the united states is very heavily
regulated okay
so um animals receive excellent vet care
shockingly better than probably lots of
citizens of this country that's another
topic
um
also there's a very
major emphasis on avoiding pain right so
i think it's probably generally true
that it's infrequent that lab animals
suffer a lot of pain researchers and
vets are very careful to avoid that
so the bigger issue is not so much are
the animals physically suffering from
pain per se but what kind of life is it
to live in a lab and be a lab animal and
i think that's a legitimate question
um
for monkeys at least where i at least
and maybe maybe in my speciesist bias
being more sympathetic to similar
species i don't know if that's
legitimate but it's a natural
increasing um they're increasing efforts
to improve the quality of life for
monkeys in in labs many monkeys are now
housed in social groups where they can
hang out with their families
and that certainly
improves their quality of life
many monkeys basically play video games
all day into carlo lab they're studying
visual perception and what do they do
they get the monkeys in there basically
doing visual tasks in in exchange for
juice rewards not all that different
from what probably lots of you guys do
now
maybe they'd be happier in nature
probably much of the time they'd be
happier in nature but i think that's
complicated too nature can be pretty
nasty so it's not totally obvious that
quality of life in
a random lab is worse than quality of
life in nature
the third point i'd say is that the
benefits of research are forever you
discover something major about how
brains work that's forever right so you
got to amortize whatever cost of animal
suffering there is against the
foreverness of that insight
um and so in my view not that you need
to agree but in my view animal research
is vastly more justifiable than things
like eating meat or buying leather
right which is just transient
entertainment or convenience
right um so anyway you guys i encourage
you all to think hard about this and to
come to different conclusions i just
wanted to note that these are
um issues that um that are worth
thinking about
um
that said
the methods in animal research are
breathtaking and they get more and more
breathtaking every day in this building
people are constantly inventing
astonishing new ways to answer all kinds
of questions and i wanted to give you
just a gist of some of the kind of stuff
that you can do
to answer that list of questions that i
said we can't really answer in humans so
just very briefly this used to be a
whole lecture but i just decided to cut
it to one slide very briefly
about 10 plus years ago these two
amazing people doris tau and vinric
freyvault who mark my words will get a
nobel prize someday
or at least they should
and they might
they
popped a monkey in a scanner
and did the very same experiment that we
do on humans
okay so here's a monkey brain again
the cortex is unfolded so you can see
the whole surface the dark bits are the
bits that used to be inside a fold the
little yellow patches are the patches
that respond more to faces than objects
just analogous to the ffa in humans but
there are six little patches in monkeys
okay so that's kind of so far that's
like okay fine monkeys have them too
that's cool
but the thing is because it's a monkey
you can then stick electrodes
straight into that region right there
and you can record from hundreds of
neurons in that region and you can
record the response of each of those
hundreds of neurons to hundreds or
thousands of stimuli you can
characterize the neural code for faces
in monkeys in a way that you just can't
for humans
okay in fact doris sao published a paper
last year called the neural code for
faces based on a decade of this research
it's quite breathtaking
okay um second you can watch those
representations change those neural
population codes change over time you
can see you know at one time point what
what the what the code seems to be
saying here and then here and then here
and you can watch that
those codes change over time in each of
those regions and you can see different
representations in each of those regions
it's quite breathtaking
you can answer this question of what are
the anatomical connections between these
regions with a whole bunch of different
methods that i won't go through here but
you can actually answer what you know
what's connected to what and what these
guys have found is that all of those
yellow face patches are connected to
each other by long-range connections
that go through the white matter
underneath the gray matter
those regions are not connected at all
to the intervening other patches of
cortex
so that set of six little regions
is like a kind of computational unit
with different hubs that that talk to
each other
okay and you can see all that in monkeys
in a way that we still don't know in
humans
you can electrically stimulate or
disrupt with other methods any one of
those patches one at a time you can
disrupt them for 50 milliseconds here
200 milliseconds there whatever you like
and you can study this whole system over
development how does it change from
shortly after birth to
uh monkey adolescence and you can
control experience during development
you can raise monkeys without ever
letting them see faces and ask whether
they're seeing a face is necessary for
the development of that region we'll
talk about that in a few lectures
my point is just that with animal
research you can answer vastly uh richer
more sophisticated questions than you
can ever answer in humans and that's
just life yes what's your name i'm
esther esther hi so assuming these
experiments they showed the monkey faces
right back done all different ways
remember monkeys see other monkeys but
they see a lot of humans too and monkey
face patches respond pretty similarly to
human faces and monkey faces
human faces respond pretty similarly to
human faces and monkey faces too even if
you don't like work in a monkey lab
okay so just to say that there are loads
of other methods and we'll get these
later in the course
okay so that snake assignment
i hope that seemed i hope that i thought
you guys for the most part did did very
well and did kind of exactly the kind of
things that we had in mind
um and i just want to go through a few
bits of terminology because i realized
some of you who messed up the wording i
hadn't really fully explained what the
different words mean
okay so first of all there's this like
incredibly boring words of independent
variables independent variables and
frankly i didn't know which was which
until i started teaching this stuff a
few years ago
but the concept is really important
right an independent variable
that's a factor that you the
experimentalist manipulate and change
so that you can then measure what effect
it has
on a brain or behavior
the effect you measure is the dependent
variable okay it's the independent
variable is called the independent
variable because you the experimentalist
get to mess with it get to manipulate it
okay the dependent one you're measuring
its dependence on the independent one
okay this is just basically any
experiment
you muck with something in in in the
world and you measure the consequences
the thing you muck with is independent
variable
the mucky the thing you measure the
effect on is the dependent variable make
sense
okay
all right so for example the bold
response that's a dependent variable and
pretty much all the experiments we'll
talk about here
all right the hypothesis most of you got
that the hypothesis is the
the statement about the world that
you're trying to figure out if it's true
in your experiment okay
um a prediction most of you got this but
let me just say prediction is supposed
to be extremely precise it's the exact
statement of what you will see when you
measure your dependent variable
if the hypothesis is true what is the
crucial thing you have to look for in
the data you measure that tells you if
the hypothesis is true or not and the
prediction is
what you will find if the hypothesis is
true
okay
confound we haven't talked about this
yet a confound
is a difference between your conditions
that you're manipulating
other than the one you intend to
manipulate
okay
and hence confounds give you alternative
accounts
case in point we compare the response in
the brain when people look at
uh faces versus when they look at a
bunch of random objects
the fact that the faces have more curvy
surfaces or are animate or are more
interesting those are all confounds with
respect to the hypothesis that that
region is responding specifically to
faces everybody got that
okay it's very common
amid undergraduates to use confound to
mean anything bad about an experiment
that's not right a compound is a very
particular thing
it's another dimension that co-varies
with the thing that you care about
it's like a nuisance variable that's
correlated with the thing you're
manipulating
and hence is giving you
a difficulty inferring
a clean
inference from your data okay
all right
a contrast
we talk about activations in the brain
like those little yellow patches i
showed in monkey brains a moment ago
that's a that shows you the bits that
responded more in functional mri when
that monkey was looking at faces than
objects the contrast is faces versus
objects
right it's like it's a looking for a
higher response in one condition than
another makes sense okay these should
all be fairly clear i just know that not
everybody got this
okay now the point of a contrast
is to isolate
a mental process
okay so let's talk about that for a
second
um
so how do we decide what contrast to use
okay
well first thing you have to do is get
clear about your hypothesis state it
explicitly most of you guys did that
really well
often your hypothesis with functional
mri at least will concern a particular
mental process that you're studying
okay like face recognition
okay now remember importantly i said
this briefly way back functional mri can
only tell you about differences between
two conditions
right the absolute number you're going
to measure the mr signal intensity in
one condition say when people are
looking at faces and it's going to be
something like 726
and it's totally meaningless okay that's
just how strong the mri signal is from
that point it doesn't mean a damn thing
on its own
okay
but then if we also measure in that same
part of the brain
uh the mr signal intensity when the
subject is looking at objects and at 720
then now we're in business
okay
all right so everything is a difference
so that means that in any imaging
experiment you'll need to compare two or
more conditions
okay one condition will never get you
anything
okay and if you want to isolate a
particular mental process you need to
turn that mental process on
or off
or you need to vary how strongly it's
turned on okay this is all in the
surface of how we're going to decide
what contrast to use that's our goal is
to turn on or off one little thing okay
and here's the problem
if i told you
okay look at my face
and don't
don't process you know low level visual
information and don't think about what
i'm saying just see my face
like it's like what you can't do that
right there's a whole processing chain
you can't just do one little mental
process at a time okay
and so that means we can't just turn we
can't just have a task where you do only
mental process x and a task where you
don't do mental process x if you're not
doing other stuff
okay
so what that means is we need to choose
two tasks each of which has lots of
mental processes but that differ in only
one
okay
so
and then we can compare those two
so this is called subtraction logic
and it comes from work over 100 years
ago in cognitive psychology and people
who are just measuring behavior this
dude donders he's a dutch physiologist
and he invented the subtraction method
to measure
reaction times in humans
way back and so with functional mri
we're doing the same thing so we're
going to come up with two different
tasks which involve the whole suite from
input to mental processing to output
and yet we're going to try to make them
differ in just one particular mental
process everybody put the program here
okay all right
um so what you aspire toward in the
contrast that you choose
is something called a minimal pair
right so the idea is we're gonna have
these two tasks
that are identical in every respect
except for that one thing we care about
okay so here's a task and here's a task
this one involves snake perception
and this one is identical to this one
except for snake perception
okay
that's what we want
okay
uh and if you get those two things
that's called a minimal pair
and this is the single most important
thing in experimental design all the
other stuff like you know how you
arrange your stimuli over time and all
that kind of stuff okay it matters a
little bit but this is the crux of the
matter what are those conditions and are
they the right kind of minimal pair okay
and you guys got the gist but i felt
like most of you didn't really engage
okay what exactly were those non-snake
conditions right so that's really the
crux of the matter okay
okay
so the most common problem with imaging
experiments is not that the scanner
wasn't as fancy as it could have been or
they didn't use the latest cutting edge
analysis method the most common problem
is that people's contrast their
conditions were not designed beautifully
enough to isolate a single mental
process
okay
okay that is that the conditions were
not minimal pairs
any other difference between the two
conditions other than the one you intend
is a confound
okay
all right
so let's engage on this now if we ran a
whole experiment um only on male
subjects is that a compound
no
why not as well
because it's not a difference between
the two experimental visions yeah it's
just a bad design feature or something
that limits your ability to draw
inferences again
like you know sub-optimal design it's
not the same as a confound content is
this very particular thing
okay
if all the snake pictures have grassy
backgrounds
and all the non-snake conditions do not
is that a compound
yeah exactly a confident right
okay so i just said all this i'll stop
pouring you okay
and the reason that the the grassy
background thing as a compound is it
gives you an alternative account of that
contrast maybe it's grassiness not
snakeness that's the key difference you
don't know okay
all right
okay so all of that said minimum pairs
are kind of like a platonic ideal of
experimental design they're what you
aspire toward but you can never really
do it right if the two conditions were
identical
um except for this one little thing
they'd be identical right you can never
totally pull it off okay but you can
track the little ways in which you fail
and you can test them one at a time in
later experiments
okay
all right
good all right so here's what we're
going to do we're going to break into
groups and you guys are going to think
how to take the kind of designs that you
already put together and turn them into
actual experiments which is going to
require
deciding on a whole bunch of other
things and then we're going to discuss
the things you come up with okay what
are the exact conditions you'll run in
your experiment so we could spend a
whole class talking about this so i'd
love to hear like your best ofs but i
don't want to engage on that for a whole
class like
you know a lot of the keys some of you
guys had very clever non-snake
conditions
uh to test
you know to get close to minimal pairs i
want to hear about those
um but then beyond that here's something
that probably none of you mentioned it's
understandable i don't think i said much
about it
what are subjects doing in the scanner
are they just lying there and the
stimuli are just flashing up and they're
going dum dee dum dee dum
are they doing something with the
stimuli go think about what you would
want to have happen okay so what is the
task
third some of you mentioned baseline
conditions but didn't really say what
they are
what would a baseline condition be and
do you want them
or is it a waste of scan time think
about that
okay
okay next suppose you get to scan 10
subjects for one hour each
now think about how that design is
actually going to go
are you going to assign different
conditions to different subjects so
these five people will see all the snake
images and these five people will see
all the non-snake images
or you're going to have snakes and
non-snakes within each subject
next
it's nice to
to not make the subject
do their task non-stop for an hour we
usually give subjects breaks so we break
an experiment into pieces of
three to ten minutes or whatever i wrote
yeah
um and so those are called runs
so think about how you wanna allocate
those conditions to runs
okay
and how many runs will you include
and then think about what's going to
happen within each run so if you're
going to have multiple conditions within
a run
are you going to stick
all the snake conditions in the first
half and all the non-snake conditions in
the second half if not why not
um
and if there are multiple conditions
within a run
yeah are you going to clump them all
together or interleave them randomly
and what are the trade-offs there
and what is the order of conditions okay
it within a run
uh and we won't get to number 10 for the
moment
okay
so
we're going to break you guys into four
groups and you're gonna talk amongst
yourselves and try to come up with your
best answers to these
in like five ten minutes something like
that and then we're gonna pull your
thoughts on this when we get back okay
okay so
part of my agenda in doing this is just
to break up the monotony of me going
blah blah blah because experimental
design is like it's important but it's
not the most riveting thing the other
thing is
experimental design is basically just
organized common sense and so most of
this stuff you guys just answered all
these questions just by thinking about
them you need to know a few things about
the the methods but really in
experimental design the the biggest the
best
guideline the best way to think about
design is think about okay you're the
subject you're lying in the scanner
you're doing that
does that work are you actually going to
be doing what you're supposed to be
doing are you going to be you know
selectively turning on and off like this
one little mental process you care about
are you doing a million other things
like falling asleep and getting bored
and
all of that and predicting what's going
to happen next and all that kind of
stuff okay
all right so let's just take a few of um
a few examples what were some of the
what were some good kinds of control
conditions that is non-steak snake
stimuli that are good to compare
uh to snakes that maybe aren't perfect
minimal pairs but that get part way
there i saw a few just in the few papers
that i looked at yeah i gotta i'm sorry
i've asked you your name like six times
but i'm gonna on my trusty sheet tell me
again how you say it okay okay okay
uh so for ours we compared snakes to
horns
to worms yeah because they have like
really similar shapes
awesome and they're both both animate
that's great
love it
what else
who else had a good controlled condition
or who had an interesting control
condition
yes sorry your name is lauren lauren yes
okay
yep our group had pretty much like the
same baseline background and we would
just superimpose images of different
objects on it so that roommate like
remained consistent throughout uh-huh
and the background was like what forest
floor
uh-huh okay so you stick you know a
toaster on the forest floor or something
like that versus a snake or something
yeah
the idea was more like other animals or
like um stuff that would make more sense
that's good that deals with the grass
confound problem right absolutely very
good what else
david you had interesting ideas well we
we
were
talked a lot about animate versus
inanimate things so like comparing it to
a garden hose yes garden hose love it i
actually ran this experiment a bunch of
years ago and we used a garden hose
or a bunch of garden hoses coiled up in
the grass we tried to make them slither
and all that anyway
but garden hose is great say more you
had other good ideas in your
yeah we also we talked about uh so my
body feels like
looking at videos like with motion
why
would you say why oh because um
uh
you know
when you see the snake it kind of
slithers and has this very distinctive
thing that is that it feels like the
motion is what creeps me out when i see
this thing totally me too and if you if
you had a rigid thing that was looked
like a snake but it was just sort of
sliding
rigidly then wouldn't really creep me
out
exactly this is a key insight right so
think about you know if we're interested
in how you perceive snakes we want to we
want to know not just how you do it in
some weird lab environment we want to
know how you'd actually do that the
whole reason to choose snakes is it
seems like something that could be
biologically relevant there might be
special hardware
when i'm out hiking and i see even a
curved stick i like jump and shriek
before i can censor myself it's horrible
i find it very embarrassing it's not
consistent with my self-image but i have
no control over it just happens and so i
thought i've thought for a long time
there's some damn bit of my brain that's
making me do that and it pisses me off
and i'm going to find it while we looked
and didn't find it but anyway
you go from those intuitions right often
your own introspections are very
informative and your i think your
intuition is exactly right there's a
very characteristic motion that snakes
have and it could be that that's the cue
so then the trick is you have slithery
motion versus what
i don't know it's hard what other kinds
of motions could you have
right so you could have just different
rigid motions where it's not slippery
what is that like changing shape
like it's just sliding or rotating
right right exactly anyway all those are
all good ideas
good um so what should the subject do in
the scanner
should they lie there and go dum dee dum
dee dum
should they do a task if so what task
oh if you guys don't volunteer i'm going
to start calling on people
even though as the jenkins study showed
it's nearly impossible to look at these
damn photographs and figure out who's
who
um
david in the back
task task or no task what tasks yes we
talked about having the subjects like
find like find a way to indicate that
they're you know paying attention yeah
and not just dosing off right so
one idea was to have them you know like
essentially indicate if they saw us make
the dinsius thing but that brought up
problems like
well we don't want them thinking about
snakes the entire experiment
also if they're going to tell you
they're seeing a snake maybe by pushing
a button then on the snake trails
they're pushing a button and the
non-snake trials are not
well on the non-stick trails they will
push another ah well then they have two
different motor responses so then we
would have them
you know run the experiment again but
good good smart
very nice
ideally
we might just have to perform a task
that's completely unrelated
to looking at snakes or thinking about
snakes just so that there's nothing
affecting you
absolutely and the point you made before
is a good one if you're looking for
snakes all the time maybe even if it
even if it's apples and dogs you're
thinking is it a steak is it a snake and
maybe you're using that region and it's
like ah that's a mess right absolutely
yeah
all right so this is a common challenge
in experimental design and these things
don't have clear right answers what i
want you to do is just see the
trade-offs you know on the one hand just
passive viewing lying there it's kind of
good in a way the things are just
impinging on your sensoria and it's
doing whatever it will do but the
downside is subjects fall asleep and get
bored and you don't know if they're
awake right so that's a problem
all right
okay and but the key thing is whatever
the task is
you don't want the task to engage
asymmetrically with a stimulus condition
because then you're building in a
confound right
right so in the group i was in we were
talking about well you could have people
well we were talking actually about
faces and objects in that case you could
have people name the things
um but you know if they're naming snakes
versus non-snakes it's not very good if
they're going snake snake snake snake
snake you know dog toast or apple right
that's like
you know
one is easier than the other and more
repetitive there are all kinds of
problems there
all right baseline conditions i didn't
really say what a baseline condition was
sorry about that
um what i meant by a baseline is
different from a control condition the
control condition would be like the
non-snakes contrasted with the snakes
right
baseline tends to be like a minimalist
condition that's supposed to you know
turn the brain off okay can we turn the
brain off
no of course not right but we can aspire
toward it we can go far part way out
there we can say okay if we're studying
vision
let's
minimize
activity in the visual system as best we
can
okay
so you could just have a blank screen
that feels like a pretty minimal thing
you could have people close their eyes
the reason that envisioned experiments
people tend to have fixation where
there's a tiny dot and subjects are
supposed to hold their eyes on it
is that in natural left to their own
devices people move their eyes a lot
several times a second and moving your
eyes produces all kinds of activity and
lots of neurons
and so it's a very kind of active visual
thing even if there's nothing on the
screen and so staring at a dot is kind
of
closer to shutting off your visual
system
even though it's not shutting it off
okay
so given that most of the contrasts
we've talked about are like faces versus
objects or snakes versus non-snakes and
all the activations that i've shown you
guys are contrast between
um
an experimental condition in a
controlled condition
why are we bothering with baseline it
doesn't even figure in that contrast
yes jimmy well like if that region is
really selected for complete stakes
you can use the baseline as the nsx like
control because like you compare the
other controller to it if it's really
selective for snakes then that non-snake
object should respond the same as the
minimal awesome everybody get that so
that's that was exactly right and this
is like a i think a very interesting
point so suppose we have
remember with mri you just have two
numbers so here's the snake response
and here's the non-snake response
if we don't have a baseline that's all
we have two numbers
okay
and that's fine you know if we run
enough subjects that could be
significant
but now let's think what else we know if
we have a baseline
suppose we have a baseline of staring at
a dot
and that's down here
we'll call that fixation
are you impressed and you run enough
subjects so that's significantly
different
are you impressed
exactly
why
because then
if the results are higher up or if the
fixation is the second one that you just
drew then the response to a snake is
twice as much as
nonstop exactly does everybody see how
yeah that might be significant but kind
of who cares right some tiny little
ratty ass effect right you know versus
if it's like here it's or or even
this is the case jimmy was talking about
like that no response at all more than
staring at a dot to the non-snakes
right
and yet this response to the snakes
that'll be even more impressive they're
different degrees of selectivity
right not just does it respond
differentially but how selective is it
oh boy i'm going way over time i'm sorry
um
so um
you guys did great kind of thinking
through these things and of course i
didn't get halfway through my lecture
that's okay we'll roll over the best
parts for later and the ones that aren't
that fun will just go by the wayside
um i will put notes on the rest of some
of these things but i think all of you
guys pulled out you know just thinking
hard about it and using common sense you
can see that a lot of experimental
design is common sense
all right see you guys on wednesday
you